it is III 2017 and we are taking a look
at a game called where the water tastes
like wine I'm here with yonniman what
does this game about yeah so this is a
game about traveling and telling stories
you kind of wander the Great Depression
era United States having these little
adventures and you get stories out of
them take these stories and you can
trade them basically with characters
that you meet to get details about their
life so it's a narrative game but unlike
other narrative games where you have one
kind of central story we instead have
these sixteen different characters and
each one of them was written by a
different person so it's sort of like a
collection of short stories in video
game form and you might recognize some
of the names of people who write for us
we have people like Austin Walker Lee
Alexander Cara Ellison Emily short some
really fantastic writers writing our
characters for us that's really cool so
do you did you play as multiple
characters then or do you play as this
character and then you find these
stories throughout the world that's
right yeah you're not playing as any of
these characters you are this character
here wandering a world finding these
stories and kind of kind of getting the
stories of these other characters the
the overall story here is that you
played a game of poker with the wrong
person and you lost and that's why
you're cursed to wander the United
States collecting these stories and
helping them helping them grow you're
sort of like the the personification of
folklore the Johnny Appleseed of folk
tales let's say okay
one thing that immediately stood out is
the music you might talk about that a
little bit yeah of course the music is
one of the big inspirations behind this
game actually this all draws from a
bunch of American roots music things
like blues bluegrass folk you know
things like that and the world that
we're trying to draw here and the Great
Depression is comes a lot from those
those songs right sort of the the world
of out of luck gamblers you know coal
miners they're selling your soul to the
devil at the crossroads stuff like that
yeah I love blues I love all that kind
of music so that was the first thing I
write when I started up I was like
alright maybe I'll just not even play
and just listen to this yeah we also um
so we have like I said there's a bunch
of different characters each of the
characters has their own own music that
goes with them we also have one kind of
overall song that changes its character
based on where you are in the u.s. also
in the Northeast it'll be kind of like
an Appalachian bluegrass sort of thing
as you go to the south it'll get more
bluesy more like a folk song in the
Midwest and so on and so forth
so I mean this is basically you're
wandering around the United States yes
this is the entire United States or the
entire contiguous United States at least
from you know you can walk from Maine to
Los Angeles if you want to this demo
takes place in in the area in the south
it's mostly Alabama they can see
Nashville kind of in the distance there
so we're about to walk into Tennessee
here but yeah the the whole United
States will be in the in is in the final
game is there something guiding you from
place to place or is it just player
exploration player freedom you stumble
across these stories right you you
mostly stumble across them when I go and
talk to one of these characters and I
tell them stories and things like that
at the end of the conversation they'll
often tell me where they're going to be
next so that can lead me if I want to
try and follow their story then that can
lead me kind of onwards through the
through the country and each of these
characters has multiple chapters of a
story going on so when I meet one even
if I get to the next chapter of their
story I'll still want to track them down
and see that that sort of content the
way that works is that as you see here
I'm talking to Althea the blues singer
who's sold her soul to the devil to be
the best in the world happens to all of
us right yeah exactly sometimes you need
to do that Althea was written by Geeta
Jackson and Geeta did an amazing job she
kind of turned this into a story more
about the lack of power that a black
woman might have in the south and this
time and and what should be willing to
do to kind of try and get out of that
and and the systems of oppression that
exist around that so here I am in the
I'm just giving through the tutorial
here but I'm here I'm in this
storytelling mode
and I can see that she asks me for for a
hopeful story is the first kind she
wanted if I tell her the right kind of
story
then I'll kind of gain her trust a
little bit right and that's how I threw
through her chapters if I gain her trust
enough the next time I meet her I'll see
the next chapter of her story okay and
another part of this game is that when
you when you kind of achieve the final
chapter of someone's story you'll also
gain their trust enough that you can see
their true inner self that's another
part of your kind of supernatural
abilities that were granted to you as
part of this curse so that's the that's
the goal here is to find all these
different characters and and see that
that sort of transformation take place
in them so I'm curious what is the
workflow like when you have 16 different
authors kind of are they kind of in
their own bubble writing their story or
if you have them interact and then once
that story is written do they help from
there is it basically on you guys where
you just integrate the story into yeah
so it's basically all the all the
writers are individual the stories don't
tie together at all except for the fact
that they all share a kind of a common
theme yeah based around the name of the
game which is where the water tastes
like wine that kind of refers to this
idea that somewhere out there there's a
place you can go where all the living is
easy and everything's great right a sort
of promised land big rock candy mountain
sort of idea but of course that that
doesn't really exist and all these
characters have stories that are about
the the failure of the American Dream to
live up to his promises in a lot of ways
but yeah so working with the author's
basically what I did was I did a lot of
research about these characters a lot of
them are historically based you know
they have antecedents in history and so
I did a lot of research around those
those people those characters I
assembled some some information and sent
that on to the writers they took that
and they turned that into real people
you know these are these are sympathetic
characters that you can interact with
talk would they have backgrounds they
have people that they know and love they
have family is all that sort of stuff
and then we take those stories and
integrate them into the game and then
we've also talked to the authors to
figure out you know Oh what do you think
that these characters
look like for example things like that
that's really fascinating feel like I've
I mean I guess a lot of games are
written by a lot of people but it's all
it seems very focused like they're all
working together but this seems seems
like you you'll have a very diverse set
of stories characters yeah that's the
idea is you know we really wanted to
make something where each character has
their own particular voice to them you
know that they they have they sound
unique they sound like a like a real
person and it sounds like a character
like this like not everyone can write a
character like that right exactly yeah
that's true so I knew that I wasn't the
the right person I could do all this
research and everything like that but I
wasn't the right person to to write all
these different characters you know we
have like sharecroppers black
sharecroppers are struggling during
Reconstruction right we have a Navajo
woman who was in the long walk of the
Navajo coal miners fighting in the the
mine strikes of the the early 20th
century and I don't have the background
to write all those characters so I went
looking for people who who might have
more to say about that than I do yeah
it's interesting because - I mean this
is a part in history that I think a lot
of people know about but it's something
that it it's it's a complex time in
history and I think it's cool to be able
to tackle it yeah something like this
absolutely and you know like I I felt
the same way that I was like oh I know
about the Great Depression and the Dust
Bowl I studied that stuff in school and
we started reading more about all these
different eras of history you realize
that there's so much more out there that
you never you've never encountered it's
not just the the president at the time
or the war going on it's like the people
are actually struggling or they're
dealing with hardships right exactly
it's not I mean like assassin's creed
for example like always takes place in
different times of history but it seems
very much like what you read in a
textbook yeah well this is kind of
getting into the more personal side of
it that's we're trying to do is we're
trying to have really personal stories
this is an interesting encounter that
we're in here what's happened here is
that because I told a story - that that
character that we we met before
that story has kind of gotten told to
other people and passed around and
everyone has maybe added their own
little embellishment to it the way that
you know folktales work in in real life
and so here I am hearing this story come
back from this person and it's kind of
grown it's turned weirder and and wilder
and so that's the way that my my
inventory of stories kind of levels up
and so the more you use your stories the
the better they get the more effective
stories we have you may not be able to
answer this but so it looks like we are
a skeleton
did did we die so this are you kind of
like a ghost sort of there's a there's
there's no clear answer to that exactly
but it has something to do with the the
the transition that took place when you
became this kind of supernatural entity
right when when you lost the game of
cards here you are transformed into this
being that you know you have some kind
of immortality and you have some other
interesting powers and part of that is
is you you have the skeleton another
reason for it is that this hopefully
allows any player to play this and feel
like this could be them because you know
it doesn't have race age gender any of
those things going on I'm going to walk
up here and show a little bit talked
about the we've got different regions of
the country and they all have their own
music they all have their own kind of
color palette they all have their own
characters you can meet and the their
own stories that you can collect so here
I am in just a tiny little bit of the
Midwest I think we if we can see now we
can't see any cities up there but yeah
this is this is the part of the country
we're in leaving the south going to the
Midwest cool so when can people expect
to play this this will be out either
later this year or early next year it'll
be coming to steam first and then we're
going to do consoles after that and
potentially even a mobile version for
tablets awesome is there anything else
going to add not really if people want
to see more about this screenshots
things like that you can go to where the
water tastes like wine calm you can
follow us and follow development on
Twitter at at Din ballgames
and yeah thanks for thanks for having us
thank you and for more ìiî coverage make
sure to stay tuned the game spot we have
more videos like this we've got all the
biggest announcements in all of the
coolest little indie games thank you so
much for watching